[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
all right let me get to handicaps
turnersportsncaa.com college basketball
analyst march madness continues tonight
usc gonzaga ucla versus michigan
and he will be with charles barkley
kenny smith and ernie johnson on studio
coverage beginning
at 6 eastern sorry to put you through
that andy good morning how are you
uh good morning dan yeah i you know i
run a lot but i'm not the prettiest
runner either
uh i don't think i could uh i don't know
well maybe i could beat steven seagal i
don't know
i don't even know like how that came up
that
paulie could outrun steven seagal
aesthetically i can oh okay you'll look
better than running that's
paulie's early years in the late 90s
all right uh give me the surprise
tonight is there a surprise tonight
and uh how does that team pull it off
uh if there is a surprise i believe it
will be ucla
uh i am picking michigan and gonzaga but
i want to qualify this as
this has been my worst bracket ever
usually i'm pretty good
but this has been my worst one ever
although in my revised
bracket i'm doing much better um
but ucla definitely can beat michigan
i think more so than usc against gonzaga
ucla has found itself they lost four in
a row
um you know the fact that johnny giuseng
and uh jaime jacquez and now jules
bernard are all playing well at the same
time
uh that had not happened in basically a
month
and so offensively they're just playing
much better i mean cody riley is sort of
by himself inside uh and that's gonna be
a problem against hunter dickinson
but ucla now can score much better than
they could
and that's why i give them a chance
certainly against michigan
explain that to me though you know these
guys are quarantined
in a bubble in indianapolis in usc and
ucla
even oregon state like they emerged from
the pac-12
that we didn't talk about the pac-12 and
now
you know here they are on the doorstep
of maybe going to a final four
well a couple things first of all um
it's not a true bubble it's not the nba
bubble where you could actually seal off
the disney compound so you know
i know this sounds very ncaa speak in
the controlled environment
but it really is not a true bubble
because there were a lot of coaches and
teams seeing each other
you know passing back and forth but you
know i do think and kenny made this
point
um a week or i guess a week ago where
because there were fewer games um you
know
usually takes sometimes by game 19 to
figure your team out
and by game 19 or 20 for some of these
teams they were in the postseason
and i do think with the case of ucla
because they had to learn how to play
without chris smith
without jalen hill and these happened
during the season um
they just needed more games and you
could argue the same thing with oregon
state
i thought usc was good all year they had
a couple of questionable games that they
shouldn't have
lost but they had the talent from the
beginning but oregon state was another
team that just got
better as the season went along because
they needed more games these teams did
not have that traditional
longer non-conference you know a lot of
them didn't play in
traditional non-conference tournaments
and so it just took longer
and then you have gonzaga they're trying
to go wire to wire
best team is gonzaga basketball power
yes um people should wash their mouth
out with
with soap if they say mid major because
it doesn't exist
in their vernacular it has nothing to do
with this program anymore
um i don't like the term anyway because
i feel like it's labeling but
i mean they travel charter everywhere
mark makes fantastic money that's
comparable to anyone around the country
now they can get games now years ago
people wouldn't come to spokane
or they wouldn't maybe they would come
to spokane at spokane arena
not to campus that's not an issue they
can get any game in the country
duke just signed up to play them in
vegas so that's not a problem
now they can get anybody in the country
uh i mean they're getting
the top literally the top recruits in
the country beating
kentucky and duke and jaylen suggs in on
this team
um you know he legitimately has a chance
to be the number one draft pick from
gonzaga
but when did it change for gonzaga or
the perception of gonzaga
i would say i think it changed with adam
morrison
um because adam morrison uh if you
remember that year
with jj redick were you know one back
and forth
with the scoring lead uh morrison was
sort of must-see tv
they never should have lost that game to
ucla that was the beginning of ucla's
run of final fours under ben howland um
but then morrison got picked by michael
jordan
i think was number three in the draft uh
maybe he shouldn't have been but he was
and um but i think that's where it
started to change
and then i think it really changed when
they played for the national
championship
in 2017 against north carolina a game
really
you know once again that they could have
and maybe should have won
because they had a lead late uh i think
around the five-minute mark so but they
gotta win a title though andy
they have to win a title like it's not
this isn't a successful season if they
don't win a title right
yeah i mean it's probably not fair to
say that in general but
yes uh they are the best team they have
the best players on the floor
uh no matter who they play against um
you know baylor's very good but i would
still take the pros
on gonzaga and the thing that you know
has been great being in the studio with
these guys
uh is you know because obviously they
have such an amazing
nba background is watching them watch
gonzaga
looking at them like an nba team and the
way they share the basketball the way
they're just their offensive rhythm
um you know the passing has been
phenomenal
you know throughout the course of the
season i mean the bounce pass
uh especially from suggs and andrew
nemhart
uh who probably does not get enough
credit the transfer from florida
he has been phenomenal for them too but
their ability to share the basketball
and be really in concert with each other
in a year where that was very difficult
because people didn't have a traditional
summer or fall that's even more
impressive
we're talking andy katz turner's sports
ncaa college basketball analyst
the coverage starts tonight with andy
charles barkley kenny smith and ernie
johnson
that'll be at uh 6 eastern on tbs
the situation with indiana with mike
woodson
is well your reaction to mike woodson as
indiana's coach
well the uh figurine in front of you of
bob knight
i think uh has already expressed himself
to be very happy with this
selection um look i think he you know
give him a chance uh
they're obviously going down this model
they weren't going to get brad stevens
unless brad stevens had been fired
you know two weeks before uh also
the current trend for the most part is
those nba coaches younger nba coaches
don't want to go back to college and
deal with recruiting so i never thought
they were getting brad
they weren't getting chris holtmann um
so the question is okay
what are they going to get scott dolson
the ad has bob knight ties to that era
uh and so there are candidates in that
pool
and they went to that pool and mike
woodson has had success in the nba
now he's older than juwan howard he's in
his 60s um
you know adding thad mata as a
consultant whatever that will mean he's
not going to be on the bench but
maybe allowing for the transition back
to college basketball
and helping him understand all that uh
will be helpful
but i think his staff will be critical
and juan howard did an unbelievable job
of building his staff
at michigan especially adding phil
martelli and that has really helped
uh connect with these players and this
game and um
uh you know we'll see how it goes yeah
but i wonder were they going to hire
thad mott as their basketball coach
he failed the physical they were
probably deep into conversations with
him and wanted to give him a job and
therefore they
made him sort of the overseer of the it
just
doesn't make any sense andy i mean thad
mata is a great college
yeah no i agree i am very perplexed by
it
um unless thad has and i have not talked
to him
uh i never really believed though when
he left because of his health issues
that he really wanted to get back into
coaching sometimes these guys like to be
wooed yeah you know to feel like they're
you know still important and wanted
uh and i think he did that dance a
little bit on a couple of jobs
but i never was convinced that he wanted
to be fully back in
to college basketball or you know head
coaching
in that form even as a martelly like
assistant
so to me i'll be very interested what
this really means is he really going to
be
living in bloomington is he just going
to be maybe in indianapolis and in
florida where he's been living
and just sort of pop in is he just on
the phone is he on zoom
is he just you know sort of like a hired
consultant
and if that's the case you know maybe
that'll work out but i'm really
interested to see just how involved
he will be we started the show i was
talking about
the the basketball game last night and
that was connecticut against baylor
the women's game and it came down to you
know a no call
at the end of the game you know you hear
officials
we talk about it do you swallow your
whistle at the end you let him play do
you allow a little more contact there
now where do you stand on that and i
don't know if you saw the play to me it
looked
like there was contact with the body by
uh one of the uh yukon women
against carrington on that shot yeah a
couple things on that dan first of all
uh if there's contact there's contact i
don't care what
time is left in the game a foul is a
foul uh you know been covering this now
for 30 years and every
coach and official will say that now
they might not like that
but it was clearly a foul you know from
what i saw
um and should have been called you know
who knows if she makes the free throws
and all that
but you know we could also be critical
that it was not a great play
uh they looked kind of lost offensively
and she ran right into traffic
uh and so it was not executed well um
but you know probably should have been a
foul two other things i just want to add
on that dan
a little soapbox moment here first off
uh dr mulcahy i don't think she's a
medical doctor or an
epidemiologist uh not sure why she
randomly went off that there should be
no cova testing here at this point
i mean we're at the we're basically near
the finish line of the two final fours
and she's preaching that there should be
no covet testing
here at the final stop that made no
sense
um and so i don't know why she even went
down that road
and then secondly um i don't
understand for the life of me because
they could have done it differently this
year
you're right that was the best game last
night why was it opposite the men or why
were the men opposite the women yeah
i don't understand why this whole
tournament
they now they won't this weekend they
finally got it right where it's the
second fourth for the women third fifth
for the men
how they have the men and women going
opposite it just makes
zero sense to me uh and you know
the ncaa should have worked with the
television partners on both sides and
said look
here's our schedule let's not have them
go against each other
yeah i'm with you on that i'm with you
on that uh hey it's great to talk to you
and play nice tonight on the set with
those guys they can they can rough you
up i know that
good to talk about a great time they've
been wonderful thank you dan that's uh
andy katz
turner sports and uh he'll be in the
studio with those guys tonight